[Musica]
[Applauso]
ciao a tutti e benvenuti a questo ed ex
organizzato all'università iulm che
ringrazio profondamente per l'invito
oggi sono qui per parlarvi di qualcosa
che
caratterizza terme ormai tutta la mia
vita sia personale che lavorativa ed è
che estremamente connesso al tema ed ex
che è quello del piano b
e oggi vi parlerò proprio
dell'esplorazione spaziale
e vi farò capire come l'esplorazione
spaziale è uno dei principali
sviluppi di questo tema del piano b
la mia
innanzitutto mi presento sono vittorio
netti sono un ricercatore all'università
di houston precisamente al six e il
sacro interaction assente alle spese
architecture è un laboratorio unico al
mondo che si occupa proprio di studiare
le strategie con il quale gli esseri
umani abiteranno è già un esplorano lo
spazio io mi occupo personalmente di
human system integration and human
factor che è proprio quella scienza che
c'è dietro
l'integrazione di esseri umani e
missioni spaziali
in questa mia avventura con lo spazio ea
è cominciata probabilmente quando ero un
bambino ho sempre
adorato
lo spazio i miei primi libri erano tutti
su l'esplorazione spaziale sulla
fantascienza ed è un sogno che a un
certo punto della mia vita ho
accantonato per poi ri scoprire alla
fine del mio percorso universitario ed
architetto
quando ho cominciato a pormi delle
domande sul sulla natura
dell'architettura ovvero sulla sua
natura come
mezzo che l'essere umano ha utilizzato
da millenni per
adattare
dei luoghi che non erano consoni e che
non erano
aderenti alla sua fisiologia per
abitarvi ed è questo il fulcro dietro la
stessa architettura che si possiamo
definire come una branca della della
extreme environment architetto lo ovvero
dell'architettura degli ambienti estremi
che è una disciplina a sua volta nata a
un certo punto della storia umana quando
abbiamo cominciato a esplorare delle
zone estremamente incompatibili con la
vita umana come le zone artiche
antartiche o i deserti per esempio le
foreste pluviali oi marì tutte queste
questi luoghi della terra quindi stiamo
parlando ancora del nostro pianeta che
erano completamente incompatibili con la
vita umana
sono stati forzati attraverso
l'architettura alla compatibilità
e
tornando un attimo a me per farvi capire
come sono arrivato a questo percorso poi
ecco dopo in studi di architettura mi
sono trasferito qui negli stati uniti
dove è saputa appunto sapevo
dell'esistenza di questo centro di
ricerca unico al mondo
dove avrei sviluppato la ricerca e
possibilmente
risposto alle domande che mi facevo
devo dire che così è stato ma al posto
di trovare risposte ho trovato solo
o meglio non solo risposte ho trovato
anche mille altre domande
l'esplorazione spaziale è il naturale
proseguo del
sogno di quella tendenza dell'essere
umano sa andare oltre i limiti a
esplorare quello che c'è oltre i confini
di quello che si conosce e lo specchio
perfetto di questa tendenza del
di noi umani alla conoscenza al ma
sempre maggiore conoscenza
e se pensate a in quanto poco tempo
questa cosa è avvenuta cioè nel senso
quanto poco tempo siamo passati dal
imparare a far volare un aereo di legno
e tessuto
al a viaggiare nello spazio è
assolutamente incredibile per quanto mi
riguarda è a un certo punto di vista di
questa esplorazione negli anni 60 con la
nascita dei primi programmi spaziali
ci siamo resi conto di qualcosa ci siamo
resi conto che forse
come abbiamo già fatto con la rit artico
come avevo già fatto con i mari come già
abbiamo fatto con gli deserti e forse lo
spazio poteva diventare la nostra una
nuova casa e per spazio non intendo solo
lo spazio profondo ovvero ciò che c'è
subito al di fuori dall'orbita terrestre
o del sistema solare ma parlo anche di
dei pianeti cioè delle altre entità
simili o dissimili dalla terra su cui
possiamo mettere piede e così è stato
non ci siamo mai fermati abbiamo
rallentato ogni tanto ma siamo spaccati
sulla luna e adesso programmiamo di
tornarci restarci è di spostarci su
marte un altro obiettivo
ben più grande
ma
perché il piano b elon musk e in un suo
famoso discorso parla della necessità di
diventare una specie multi planetaria e
lo fa proprio in ragione
della non esistenza di un piano b per
l'umanità
cosa succede se
un cataclisma una una malattia
estremamente infettiva o un altro
disastro anche anche pasquato
casato dall'essere ma lo stesso porti
all'estinzione o all'incompleta
incompatibilità della dell'ambiente
terrestre ovvero il nostro ambiente
natale con la vita umana
beh la proposta di damasco è proprio
quella cioè di diventare una specie
molti planetaria cioè di diventare una
specie che non ha più una sua casa ma ne
ha diverse nel cosmo
trovo estremamente affascinante questo
concetto concetto perché a parte come la
conoscenza di cose come
il cambiamento climatico e le
trasformazioni che l'uomo ad opera sul
sulla terra ci hanno portato a
capire che nulla è dato per scontato ma
io trovo che questo sia l'unico vero
futuro nel quale noi possiamo muoverci
come razza umana
vivere nello spazio però è estremamente
complicato ed estremamente complicato
perché lo spazio per definizione è
l'ambiente più invivibile che possiamo
immaginare
stiamo parlando in un ambiente in cui
non solo manca l'ossigeno che è quello
di cui qui respiriamo è quello che
alimenta il processo energetico nel
nostro corpo ma abbiamo una marea di
condizioni avverse come possono essere
le radiazioni o
e temperature estreme
possibilmente anche
contaminazioni
interpretare provenienti da altri mondi
con i quali non siamo mai entrati in
contatto prima e allora perché vogliamo
arrivare a vivere nello spazio perché il
nobel dov'è il nostro
perché il nostro futuro si sta muovendo
in questa direzione beh perché ormai
il pianeta terra è comincia a diventare
a starci stretto certo punto di vista
perché è impossibile arrestare questa
volontario infinita di espressione
dell'essere umano ma quello di cui vi
voglio parlare oggi sono proprio le
regioni cioè nel senso come abitare lo
spazio come
quale i quali sono i mezzi come possiamo
arrivare da dove siamo oggi
all questo futuro di specie moti
planetari
beh innanzitutto dobbiamo riuscire a
capire come
superare tutti questi ostacoli
ambientali ed è una cosa che abbiamo
cominciato a fare già dagli anni 50
quando abbiamo mandato le prime capsule
prima con animali e poi con esseri umani
in orbita terrestre abbiamo cominciato a
sperimentare come proteggerci come
costruire delle
diciamo un ambiente entra nel come
portare con noi quell'ambiente e invece
ci garantisce la sopravvivenza e in
decenni di esplorazione spaziale di
permanenza nello spazio abbiamo imparato
tantissimo
vi ricordo che ad oggi
dal 2011 non viviamo più neanche sulla
terra tutti insieme ce ovvero la
popolazione umana
scendiamo c'è sempre qualcuno a tempo
pieno nello spazio in questo e nel caso
in cui vi parlo prima solo della
stazione spaziale internazionale iss
che esiste passi dal 2001 e poi adesso
dopo da pochissimo tempo come forse a
quelli voi sanno anche una nuova
stazione spaziale che quella cinese
ma tutti questi
questi diciamo queste questi tentativi
di vivere nello spazio e di farlo sempre
più a lungo e sempre in maniera più
continuata per riuscire a validare
queste teorie di abitare lo spazio ci
hanno anche rivelato
tantissimi altri problemi che dobbiamo
ancora risolvere uno dei problemi
principali che abbiamo scoperto può
essere estremamente dei lividi
debilitante per l'essere umano è proprio
la gravità e noi ci siamo venuti in un
ambiente con una determinata gravità e
il nostro corpo è l'intera nostra
fisiologia e basata su quel concetto il
flusso sanguigno scorre in maniera
diversa in microgravità ovvero quella
condizione in cui gli astronauti
fluttuano in orbita terrestre che non è
mancanza di gaeta
i nervi vengono schiacciati perché non
soggetti a la normale gravità terrestre
gli astronauti spesso perdono scegli di
vista grazie all'accumulo di sangue in
determinate parti del corpo che non
sarebbero previste perché siamo abituati
alla gravità diverse quindi per esempio
uno dei principali temi della ricerca
nel campo
dell'esplorazione futura dello spazio
quella della gravità artificiale
ci sono tante teorie in proposito una
delle più accreditate è che è stata
anche parzialmente testata in spazio e
quella delle centrifughe gravitazionali
ovvero l'idea di costruire delle
stazioni spaziali
che con che abbiano un asse di rotazione
talmente grande e parliamo per generare
una gravità utile a controbilanciare gli
effetti negativi del della microgravità
di più o meno di un raggio di 85 metri
di e appunto di 5 metri di distanza
quindi parliamo di stazioni molto grandi
che potrebbero ruotare ad una velocità
tale da riprodurre l'effetto della
gravità terrestre
questo risolverebbe tantissimi problemi
perché molti altri problemi li abbiamo
già superati come la protezione dalle
radiazioni
che
è uno dei pochi motivi per cui si
riusciamo a sopravvivere lo spazio anche
se determinati
problemi correlati come quello della
radio delle tempeste solari sono ancora
una diciamo un campo di ricerca
estremamente aperto
ma non solo un altro aspetto importante
e poi se possiamo dividere
l'architettura spaziale e l'abitabilità
dello spazio in due grandi famiglie
ovvero quelle della
degli ambienti e
deep space
n orbit cioè nel senso
nello spazio profondo è nell'orbita
planetaria quindi in un ambiente nel
quale sfruttiamo in presenza di una
gravità estremamente ridotta
come la stazione spaziale gravitazionale
un altro grande tema è quello della
costruzione planetaria cioè sulla
superficie dei pianeti come la luna e
marte io ho lavorato l'ultimo anno
nell'impatto gruppo della nostra per di
sviluppare la prima infrastruttura
lunare di superficie ne è che dovrebbe
essere costruita a partire dal 2028
è l'idea è che secondo me è estremamente
interessante da questo punto di vista è
quella di
di costruire utilizzando le risorse in
situ che è poi in realtà nulla li verso
ciò che facciamo sulla terra sulla terra
noi utilizziamo il cemento utilizziamo i
materiali intorno a noi per edificare
gli edifici in cui viviamo
e perché non dovremmo fare anche questo
sulla luna o su marte
questo ci risparmierebbe tantissimi
problemi come quello di portare e
tonnellate e tonnellate di materiale
dalla terra che oltre a essere poco
pratico e anche poco sostenibile e in
questo ci vengono in aiuto tantissime
nuove tecnologie come a quella della
stampa 3d
attualmente molte aziende
in giro per il mondo già stampano
edifici residenziali case e stampate con
con materiali cementizi in 3d
e quindi noi possiede la l'aspetto
secondo me super affascinante
dell'esplorazione spaziale e che non è
mai fine a se stessa non è mai fine a se
stessa perché tutte queste tecnologie
che noi sviluppiamo per lo spazio per
ritorno nella sua terra e ci aiutano a
migliorare la vita sulla terra e vi
parlo di cose come per esempio
le tecnologie satellitari
la cura delle malattie le tecniche delle
tecnologie mediche
i vantaggi che hanno portato per la vita
sulla terra
tutte queste scoperte fatte grazie alla
ricerca
spaziale sono in quantificabili
ma quindi cosa ci aspetta da questo
futuro
dell'umanità multi planetaria
beh ci aspetta un mondo anzi a questo
punto un sistema solare per non dice un
universo estremamente
affascinante perché ancora tutto da
scoprire
molto probabilmente nei prossimi decenni
andremo incontro a una nuova epoca di
esplorazione come non se ne erano visti
dai campi della scoperta dell'america
imprese nuove scoperte nuove
esplorazioni
nuovi coloni nuovi esploratori è tutto
un nuovo mondo che si che si sta
dipanando
dinanzi ai nostri occhi e lo vediamo
ogni giorno quando sentiamo parlare
delle
perseverance su ingenuity il primo drone
su marte ho parole diamo i razzi di elon
musk prepararsi per le prime missioni
marziale
io in tutto questo spero di
aver di essere riuscito a ad affascinare
o almeno a trasmettervi il lo stupore
con cui affronto ogni giorno questo tema
sia nel mio lavoro che nella mia vita di
tutti i giorni vi ringrazio ancora per
per essere stati con me quest'oggi e
spero di vedervi presto chissà magari
sulla luna o su marte